sehe ich so aus willich salat essen gut
einem monat habe ich schon auf die rtl2
hilf mir folge meinen freunden mästet
mich reagiert und hab ich gerade mal
wieder so die kommentare geschaut und da
ist einfach alles voll gesperrt mit hey
lukather von pizza und zweiten teil
darauf reagieren wir heute hier sind
gerade drei sekunden in der folge und
man sich direkt wo die reise heute
wieder hingeht mit dem niveau meine
damen und herren uns war nämlich ganz
nach unten da wo sie ihr fett hat
falls ihr übrigens erst mal die erste
folge nicht gesehen hat noch nicht wisst
was hier abgeht das hier ist der louis
und der louis liebt die ashley was der
louis allerdings an der sg am meisten
mag ist ihr fett
und das
lässt er sie und will sie mit diesen
ganzen süßigkeiten so dick kriegen wie
es nur irgendwie geht hält sich
bescheuert an
ist es auch ja es hat rtl 2 zentimeter
mehr
ich habe gesagt so stolzen erst so stolz
auf sie mensch zwei zentimeter mehr das
wird er lud sich untenrum wahrscheinlich
auch wünschen ihre genommen zur feier
des tages habe ich dir noch was
mitgebracht
acht stück alle nur für dich
8 kroos
ja sehr
schauspielerisch nicht schon genug fans
butter drauf
ich will jetzt schon nicht mehr auf dem
perfekten körper da bin ich wieder aus
dem wasser
das ist fremdschämen
level
so dass die erde da
und wenn wir das niveau betrachtet das
ist ca da ganz ganz ganz arg die machen
jetzt so ein rückblick was bisher
geschah vor diesem kurs und dem festmahl
hier so kommst du nämlich auch mal an
die frische luft und in meine ohne
unseren plan thread in dem wagen
verbrennt du nämlich keine einzige
kalorien ein punkt natürlich doch alles
meine damen oder hast du hingehen
der transportierte ihn im bollerwagen
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zu deutschen fern film hier
sieht man wie sehr die session
kontrolliert und manipuliert und er
schließt das aus liebe zu ihm mit sich
machen ehrlich hoffentlich merkt sie
bald dass liebe eigentlich etwas anderes
bedeutet an rtl2 stelle dich dafür die
pädagogen eingestellt wenn ich die
beiden so durch mein viertel spazieren
sehen würde alter ich würde beide auf
dem kopf packen ehrlich gesagt mir darf
ich sie zum essen einladen ruhe
ganz kurze info für euch eben mira ist
die beste freundin von der ashley und
die mira will dass die er schließlich
von louis trends also ich bin gespannt
was die reaktion von luisa beste freunde
ok
das 60 grad in sofort aus ich bin
gemeldet hat ist einfach in ihrem
schreiben
klink
das wäre welcher regisseur denkt sich
das aus und denkt sich haye die beiden
müssen dass zeitgleich sagen damit
zeigen wir den anderen leuten wie sehr
die wirklich befreundet sind wirklich
damit du groß bist oder was du willst du
vergiften ich schaue mir ja dann haben
wir am wenigsten was vernünftiges zu
lassen
ist so ihren bruder luis will die pizza
essen das was glaube ich mich hin kommt
natürlich 2 der louis wie man ihn kennt
deshalb ist echt gut aus probiere ich es
gleich eine pizza stimmt warum sollte
man salat essen wenn man noch danach
eine pizza ist also allgemein warum
sollte man auch duschen wenn man danach
wieder schwitzt doch der raum sollte man
sich die zähne putzen wenn man ein paar
stunden später wieder was ist für dich
satt essen
das ist doch völlig ungesund was hat
sogar gesagt komm ich zeig dir das war
voll ungesund
also wirklich wer sich die konversation
ausgedacht hat schreibt mir bitte bei
instagram
das ist das ist weltklasse projekt okay
jetzt jetzt kommen wir wahrscheinlich zu
offen zum aufeinandertreffen der
giganten
mira und louis das ist unfassbar dass
sich die als giganten betiteln auch wenn
lewis der täter ist er braucht ganz
dringend hilfe aha okay das ist das ist
super dass das doch mal von der
pädagogin jetzt gesagt wurde und islam
strikt keinen menschen haben sorry ich
schaff das besser verstehen das ist
asozial sagt ihm abrieten liebe zu tun
du hast halt die fresse
[Gelächter]
was ist deine lieblings pizza also
entweder thunfisch oder margherita weiß
ich auch aber ich würde einfach mal
sagen mal geriet eine salami ok salami
fallen die meisten ich hab kein bock auf
das ist scheiße los keine ahnung
brauchen sie okay
jetzt sind wir wieder in der gegenwart
also diese echt wahnsinn wie sie die
pizza verschränkten teilchen ist noch
nichts übrig bleiben das habt ihr doch
versprochen
ihr müsst mir überlegen es darf nichts
übrig bleiben drei pizzen 2 liter cola
kutter die akkus noch irgendwo und hier
noch chips ganz normales abendessen wenn
ich wieder kollegen nicht auf jeden fall
in das mesz mit ja das ist gut ich kann
mich auf dich verlassen oder die ashley
tut mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen leid
also nicht nur in dieser folge sondern
ich glaube auch dass die schauspielerin
das nicht noch mal machen würde aber er
steht sich leider nicht sehen habe also
verpiss dich da wo du hergekommen weil
alter okay die beiden prallen wieder
aufeinander ich weiß sie haben die sich
gerade irgendwie aus zufall der stadt
getroffen habe aber mal schauen was
jetzt sprechen wenn du nicht aufpasst
bei erste gegen mich zu hetzen
siehst du sie nie wieder sehen das
schwächt die alter der louis ein
bisschen gewalttätig louis du kriegst du
jetzt wochen hausarrest
aber lukat gesprochen hast du krank bist
du sollst verbissen an
o
das hat er nicht gesagt was
schon getroffen schade das war dass das
ist aha aha das ist nötigung wenn ihre
in anzeigt erwarten mindestens eine
saftige geldstrafe
aber okay danke gott jetzt spannend
freuen es wird spannend ok
wie kommt sofort sie ist wirklich wie
eine schlichte in dem tempo unterwegs
auf dem weg nach zu klopfen waren
sie drückt dagegen
alter
keine haustür geht nach außen auf die
meisten fürs zu dazu eben diese szene
beschreibt komplett hilf mir mit der
hand versuchte die tür aufzumachen aber
mit dem fuß
und mit ihrer anderen hand drückt sie
die tür zu
ja verliere ich nicht so langsam den
glauben an die menschheit was ich auch
richtig stark finde ist hier wo die mir
eigentlich gerade saß und gegessen hat
das ist komplett freigeräumt und klima
also da wurden die szenen auf jeden fall
ein richtiger reihenfolge abgedrehte rtl
scheiße die er schnell liegt da
kannst dich doch
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt okay die
mira hatte schlüssel gefunden sie alt
jetzt superman like zu tür kommt zurück
ich will mir darf sich mehr angucken das
geht doch drei minuten
ich habe das immer bei hilf mir das ab
hälfte wünsche keinen bock mehr
dann ganz am ende denk mehr willkommen
ich würde mein youtube kanal der louis
zeigt wahrscheinlich muss man hätte noch
zehn croissants mehr gegessen dann wäre
sie jetzt topfit ashley hat
schwerwiegende gesundheitliche probleme
als meine freundin ist zusammengebrochen
sechs wochen später
das wartet das war's
dies zusammen gebrochen sechs wochen
später und dann
ja super super zeitlicher übergangen ich
bin ja wirklich dankbar dass du immer zu
mir gehalten hast und es ist für mich
auch typisches mädel geschwafelt hey wir
sind so tolle blümchen freundin du
machst ja alles für mich ich mache alles
würde
das wichtigste ist mit sich selbst
zufrieden zu sein egal was andere dazu
sagen da muss ich wirklich zum ersten
mal sagen das war eine gute aussage
dadurch aber noch schöner gut diese
reaktion wenn ich meine action video
hier gefallen hat dann lass gerne mal
einen daumen hoch unter diesem video da
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare ob ich eventuell wieder mal
auf hilft mir reagieren soll
ich habe zwar irgendwie 23 woche noch
keine folge reagiert weil es eine scheiß
serie ich will nicht dass mein kanal nur
aus hilf mir besteht so das kenne ich
irgend ein bisschen komisch deswegen ja
ich mir gesagt kommen jetzt mal wieder
nach zwei wochen soll ich noch mal auf
eine folge reagieren schreibt mir gern
und in den kommentaren
ich bin weiterhin mit der rtl zwar in
kontakt bezüglich meiner
ja dass ich vielleicht auch mal einer
folge mitspielen darf absoluter traum
aber sollte ich mich dass wir jetzt auch
beenden
[Musik]